[Music]
in other news according to a recent
article
health officials are reporting that a
growing number of americans are
contracting covid
despite being fully vaccinated and
no no thank you i don't want anything to
do with this yeah
i don't want to talk about that or think
about that
at all you see
some news gives me the blues
some news makes me feel pissed but some
news is just so bad baby i pretend
it doesn't exist still getting covered
after the vaccine
no thank you that just doesn't exist
some news makes me feel joy
some news fills me with this
but some news is just so bad
baby i pretend it doesn't exist
like this republican senator tim scott
said recently that
america is not a racist country and
president biden
and vice president harris agreed with
him
now i'm going to pretend like that news
story doesn't exist
is that healthy no tarik nothing i do is
healthy
[Music]
some news i take to heart
some news i just dismissed
but some news is just so bad baby
i pretend it doesn't exist like this
trump was reportedly presented with a
24-page proposal
to launch his own multi-billion dollar
media company
yeah i don't think so cause like what
that would mean for people i
that just doesn't exist it doesn't exist
no baby it doesn't exist
no no no baby it doesn't exist
[Music]
that news doesn't exist
[Music]
you